We've been waiting and waiting to do this
story to get the latest information, but we're
just not getting any better information to
reset.
Monday night, there was a democratic caucus
in Iowa.
After getting one or 2% of the vote, the vote
stopped coming in irregularities, quality
control, a crashed app.
On Tuesday, we got 62% of the vote.
By Wednesday we had 71% of the vote.
By Thursday we had 97% of the vote and then
all of a sudden the DNC says, we want to start
over.
We want to re canvas all of the results.
So I'll just give you the numbers I have right
as of right now, P Buddha judge is ahead by
0.1% of the vote and by three state delegate
equivalence.
This will work out in the end, no matter who
ends up winning.
This is going to work out roughly to the same
number of pledge delegates for Bernie Sanders
and for Pete Buddha judge, unless the numbers
that we have so far are just completely wrong.
There are numerous questions about this, but
as always, the real story is that we knew
from the start with proportional apportionment
of delegates, the leaders, likely the front
runners, we thought it would be Biden and
Bernie.
It ended up being booted.
Judge and Bernie, they're going to have roughly
the same number of pledge delegates and this
is going to be a fight for way longer than
Iowa.
This is about momentum and claiming victory.
Many relevant questions from the Iowa caucus.
Does it make sense for Iowa to keep going?
First, the answer is no.
Dealt with that on yesterday's show is our
entire system of primaries and caucuses broken
very much so.
We dealt with that on yesterday's show.
Is the DNC in shambles and in an embarrassing
situation?
Yes, we dealt with that on the Wednesday show,
but then now the latest news is that democratic
national committee chair, Tom Perez came out
and said, we need to re canvas all of the
results because now there are questions about
accuracy even of what's been announced so
far.
To recap, this is essentially to double check
the vote hand auditing.
A Iowa election officials would have to hand
audit the caucus worksheets and the reporting
forms to make sure at every level the votes
translated correctly to the caucus worksheets
to the reporting forms and so on.
This is another reason why we should just
have a primary to start, not a caucus.
And arguably we should get rid of caucuses
altogether.
It's insanity.
And Viv, in a few days, we're going to be
on to New Hampshire.
The reality all along was that whether Pete
or Bernie win in Iowa by one or by two or
by three or by five percentage points, it's
not going to make a difference to the longterm
math.
And it's more about this being another one
of these endemic unfortunate realities in
the political machinations, machinations,
machinations, um, of the DNC and of corporate
politics and of the establishment efforts
to influence this election.
So before you know it, we're going to be talking
about New Hampshire results.
Bernie and Pete, essentially tide will likely
come out of this with the same number of pledged
delegates, if not varying by maybe one delegate.
It's an embarrassment, but that's where we
are as of right now.
Let me know what you expect in terms of, uh,
shenanigans between now and the DNC.
I'm on twitter@deepakthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com